[Musica]
francisca sapevo che saresti venuto
carla bruni ass
francesca non devi fare una cascina
smettila di nascondere i tuoi sentimenti
tirali fuori carla bruni
quanti altri sentimenti devo tirare
fuori in questa serie sono già sta dalla
spaventata preoccupata interdetta grassi
l'indagatrice curiosa allo stremo delle
forze la pratica seriosa influenza la
spianata nervosa agitato da basi legali
felice
ti prego smetti di essere così
insistente francisca francisca o
francisca per in primis perché non vuoi
capire che io ti amo dalle pagine ma
devo dirti una cosa sono rimasta incinta
di mia cugina gengivali non è possibile
scusate per questa cosa che ho in testa
ma mi stava asciugando i capelli e
volevo fare il video e quindi alla fine
mi sono detto facciamo il video
asciugando mi capelli è dovuto mettere
oppure uno qui sulla barba per asciugare
numero però ciao a tutti allora sapete
tutti quanti che una delle cose che a me
più diverte e scrivere mi piace un sacco
a scrivere video invece un sacco
scrivere i capolini e su un blog aperto
recentemente e sopra ogni cosa e sono
riuscito a pubblicare il mio primo
romanzo che è questo qui maggiori
informazioni stanno qua sotto io ho
finalmente capito cosa voglio fare la
vita quindi sono molto contento perché
ho deciso che la mia carriera sarà
quella di sceneggiatore di porno
io credo onestamente di essere portato
che caldo
la farsa
papà adottivo per il suo nome in
matematica lo stesso amico di famiglia
poiché albergatori di montagna non
riesco a dormire
sono entrambi con il resto bisogno del
tuo aiuto ma non sanno sesso prima di
parlare di film porno che sicuramente
una cosa nella quale parlerà il futuro
visto che comunque di interesse pubblico
il mio piccolo volevo dare delle dritte
descrivere qualcosa di successo le
telenovelas e analizzando tutto quello
che miranda si vede ho scoperto che
esistono sei cliché presenti tutte le
sue opere di successo avere un sacco di
parenti deve diventare tipo 8 sul futuro
questo il momento della verità francisca
di melo che è che ha ucciso suor cesino
alla suocera mia sorella france ma io
credevo che tu fossi figlia un piano lei
è stata generata per non creata dalla
stessa sostanza del padre ma come è
possibile è per colpa della sorella
della mia sorella che avevi detto che è
stata una delle in immagine dirmi cosa
dire
io gli ho creduto capisce o non ti
capisco francisca spiegati meglio il
quadrato del nonno x il quadrato della
zia e wen all'assassino quindi sta
cercando di dire che è uguale di squadre
ovvero avere delle teste sensibilissime
perché solo in questo modo penetra
possibilità di far entrare in coma
qualsiasi personaggio della
da sopra gli potrebbe far cadere per
sbaglio di protesta proprio il fan a
sbattere contro un armadio si può fare
la coda si può fare ci sono i capelli di
n
l'importante è che entrò in coma per un
po ci arriviamo dalle palle che scena
insieme alla fissa per un sacco di
parenti c'è la fissa del incesti
all'interno delle soap c'è la fis devo
scoprire che i due che sia ma non certo
punto sono fratello e sorella in modo da
farli vivere proprio male questo cuore a
far divenire leone c'era questi poveri
ragazzi per far scoprire sempre medesimi
dopo 500 puntate che detta si sono
sbagliate l'anagrafe e che inventa sono
due perfetti sconosciuti e che quindi
possano bombare in allegria senza farsi
troppi problemi il ritorno dal mondo dei
morti
se c'è una cosa che ho capito è che le
telenovelas come la bibbia i personaggi
possono resuscitare senza troppi
problemi anche con le scuse più becere
l'importante che le suscitino meredith
io ero sicuro che tu fossi formati ho
visto annegare con i miei stessi occhi è
in realtà sono una soluzione rizzoli in
b o nica mamma tu sei morta partorendo
ne è una madre lavora è questa chi è
allora quindi la reggina non mi è mai
stata mangiata quindi silente non è
morto michael jackson in concerto
nemmeno detto che c'è non le compete la
punizione del sesso è un altro argomento
importantissimo sei protagonisti fanno
all'amore bevono assicuri di qualche
modo se la tipa viene deflorata per la
prima volta
lehmann incinta se lui fanno l'amore uno
dei due muore se i due si concedono ai
peccati della carne deve succedere un
qualcosa di orribile se i personaggi
fanno sesso non c'è grattata di palle
che tenga e infine la tecnica superman e
se all'interno di una telenovela un
attimo a link ciao all'interno di una
telenovela
qui c'è il casinò scusate perché ormai
ci stanno emozionando tutti ma sia un
personaggio si mette gli occhiali
diventa irriconoscibile cardenas nel del
momento di dirti addio francisco come
possibile tombolini giurato cananà non
sono fatti per stare insieme mio padre
non lo vuole
ho deciso scomparire io ho sempre
immaginato maybin in una baita in
montagna come i bambini
tu che sai non ci è dato saperlo e con
questo vi saluto ciao vado asciugarmi
capelli